you're the first Thames Water CEO to
have given a broadcast interview for at
least 10 years why is the company being
so shy in the past well it's difficult
to see why it was shy in the past but I
know why I'm here today and that's you
know it's incredibly important for us to
make sure we're engaging with our
customers and you know guys like you and
programs like this are a very important
way for us to do that now one of the
things you've said today is that
shareholders aren't gonna get a dividend
this financial year is that recognition
that shareholders have taken too much
cash out of the company in the past I
think it's more to do with the fact that
you know when we look at where we are
today and the challenges that we face as
a business we've got to make difficult
decisions about how we use cash and your
weather pretty big discussion with our
with our board and there was real
unanimity around the table that said
what we've got to do is put our
customers first and investing wisely
right now is more important than paying
dividends and the shareholders got that
the shareholders absolutely we're you
know the part of that decision and
completely endorsed it one of the things
you've said today is that you're gonna
miss your leakage targets again this
year when do you expect to start hitting
them so I think it's going to be 2020
before we be get back on target but
quite an ambitious target quite a big
big reduction and as you say we missed
it last year so we've got to catch up
that work as well as do everything else
that we were going to do but I'm very
confident we're going to be back on
track by 2020 that's three years out of
those divas yeah pretty unacceptable
isn't it yeah well you know when you
look at the thousands and thousands and
thousands of kilometres of pipes that we
operate it's it's a big task and you
know the thing with infrastructure
businesses is you don't turn on a
sixpence so what's important for us is
to make sure we've got the right
long-term targets and then we stick to
it so far we're on track and you know
we're going to sustain that effort but
this means presumably you'll resign to
another heavy fine this year from
off.what yeah I expect we'll be you know
more you know by news for us in that
sense but what I want to make sure is
that you know we'll set this recovery
plan
and that month-by-month we hit of
recovery targets and then we're gonna
get there
winter 2016 you had a lot of very
high-profile burst water mains can you
guarantee that isn't gonna happen again
this winter no I was loved to be able to
guarantee that but you know what I don't
think that that's realistic what we've
done on the back of those Boris was to
take a pretty deep strategic review of
those big pipes and one of the things
that we have got to do is to make sure
that we respond more quickly and better
to those incidents and we recently had
one in Houston actually and I'm
delighted to see I can actually see real
improvements in that space
beyond that we are in the middle of our
long-term plan just now and I think over
the next six to nine months we'll be
coming back with a plan to really
replace probably a significant amount of
those pipes
but again the this poor record on
leakage these these bursts I mean this
is again recognition surely that the
company hasn't invested enough in the
past and that shareholders have
extracted too much cash out of the
business well you know it's it's
difficult for me in a way to talk about
about the past but we also have to
accept you know that we have some legacy
issues so you know as a CEO of the
business what I've really got to do is
to make sure I've got alignment with our
investors including our new investors to
make sure that we are taking the
business forward and actually going to
meet those challenges you've just done
actually gonna close down to Cayman
subsidiaries why were those businesses
there in the first place you know this
is way back in the midst of time I think
probably over over ten years ago and I
think at that point in time they were
necessary to set up the financial
structure under which the business
operates today to be honest they're of
no real importance to the business and
we are going to get rid of them because
you know it sort of gets in the way even
the law they have no real practical
impact on the way we operate the
business we don't really want to be
associated with with anything which is
less than completely transparent yeah I
mean it creates a bad look doesn't it
Aster's the fact that Thames paid no
corporation tax between 2011 and 2015 I
mean that's really unacceptable isn't it
yeah so I mean the corporation tax are
things really interesting
when you look at businesses there's lots
of reasons why businesses may not pay
corporation tax the first thing I would
say about our position is that it's not
that we don't we're not ever gonna pay
this is deferred and its deferred
because we've got the a very very large
investment program and clearly that you
know there are government schemes to
encourage investment and very
importantly the benefit of that tax
deferral all goes to our customers none
of the benefit will go to investors it
all results in lower bills sorry how
does that work so in effect if we were
paying that tax obviously we would be
paying out more money and that
incremental money that we were paying in
terms of tax we'd be translated into
higher bills for our customers so the
great thing about the government schema
is a it's good for our investment as a
business and B it's good for our
customers because we actually are able
pay lower bills on the back of that what
about the political backdrop I mean it's
often said that the rest of the water
cut industry ab c-- hates thames also
because you brought the wrath of jeremy
corbyn down on the entire sector he
wants to nationalize you all and it's
all because of the way tensors
historically being run well I'm not sure
if that's the case actually I'm not
actually the chat with Jeremy to find
out the origins or phase of his plans my
relationship with other water companies
actually is very strong you know you
know Thames of course we are we are
large and more important but we're only
one of you know nearly 20 over 20 water
companies in the country and I think
what is important that you know as a
group there are many issues that we can
cooperate on and that's what we like to
focus on but we I mean would you be open
to meeting Jeremy Corwin of course I
would be open to meeting Jeremy I think
it's very important that you know just
in the way that I'm talking to you that
we as a business are open and and of
course we do we meet labour politicians
conservative politicians Liberal
Democrats and many or other other
stakeholders being open and being
transparent and engaging with
politicians and with any practice even
more importantly our customers is
central to the way that I want to run
the business
where's this impetus for change come
from well you know it's an interesting
question I don't think there's a simple
answer to that I think it's partly you
know a historical place we're at you
know in a wave when we talk about for
instance those big trunk means it's a
bit like your car you can keep
maintaining it our point it's time for a
new one and I think if you look at
historically a lot of our infrastructure
we're at that point where we really need
to think about renewal so I think that's
part of the impetus I think partly it's
the regulatory environment and the way a
regulator is leading the business which
I feel endorsed by the way the focus on
customers and also I think there's a
change in the zeitgeist you know the
importance of the environment the
challenge of climate change I think
these things combine to say we need to
respond in a new and innovative in a
different way so what would you like to
be how would you like Thames to be
viewed say twelve months from now at
this time legendary so I think you know
the first thing is you know talk is easy
isn't it you know it's easy for me or
I'm leading amazing business I love it
and I will talk enthusiastically about
it but actually action is more important
and I think in 12 months time I want us
to still be on track to recover our
leakage target I want us to have reduced
the number of pollutions again we're you
know over the last three or four years
we've reduced it by nearly 50 percent I
want that to continue and also wanted to
continue engaging with our customers you
know in the last six months we opened up
a fantastic thing in Walthamstow is one
of Europe's largest urban wetlands the
day it opened 5,000 local people walk
through the gate to experience this
fantastic environment and I want to
continue that engagement with our
customers whether it's that but also
things like you know you'll have heard
about our famous fatberg yes it's very
important the only thing that should go
down a toilet is pee poo and paper
remember that the three P's we want to
avoid those fatbergs and the way that we
can do that is not to lecture but to
engage so in 12 months time I want to
see continuing that openness
that transparency in that customer
engagement